but you see these people with a mental
like literally mental disorders and
another phenomenon that I see just from
interviewing women after women after
women is really these chicks having
mental disorders
um to the point where you interview
women on the street you say rate
yourself one to ten they say ten why do
they think that because the attention
they're getting is the level of a 10 10
years ago we get so much attention from
Instagram
um the likes we edit our pictures we
literally think we look different and
it's so interesting because they come on
the show and sometimes I'll follow them
after the show I don't know I'm a nice
I'm a nice gal occasionally and
it's so crazy sometimes I don't even
recognize them